[Musique]
bienvenue à l'elysée bienvenue à toutes
et tous une ambiance de fête qui détonne
pour un lendemain de défaite hier soir
la musique résonne dans la cour de
l'elysée mais toujours aucun mot du
président sur la déroute de son parti
aux régionales comme si de rien n'était
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la soif de pouvoir en général ça se
transforme en quelque chose de mauvais
une fois au pouvoir
emmanuel macron qui prend même le temps
de poser avec la star canadienne justin
bieber en visite au palais à part les
chaussures ça va pourquoi on doit encore
retrouver donc on met pas de basket avec
un costume jusqu'à l'elysée qu'est-ce
que manager vous êtes mais ça lui arrive
de temps en temps de me dire maman
j'aime pas commenter habillé là je pense
avoir à l'écouté parce que je sais que
les petites filles
j'essaie que vous regardez là les deux
shows pis ça me fait énormément plaisir
je sais que vous êtes au tac avec un
mode
alors n'hésitez pas du vote moment elles
font des fashion faux pas ou pas sur la
place de l'hôtel de ville aussi
plusieurs centaines de jeunes réunis
sans respect des règles sanitaires
malgré le monde peu de débordements ont
été constatés
place de la république la police a dû
toutefois utilisé des gaz lacrymogènes
pour disperser la foule
ces premières soirées qu'on est vraiment
le couvre-feu plus de masques perso je
trouve que c'est normal que voilà tout
le monde soit là font par l'afev et
touche donc s'étoffe
mais comme l'a dit jérôme c'est la
pauvreté de leur vocabulaire et leur
incapacité totale à avoir un
raisonnement
oui ça mais je ne vous fais une
limitation qui se nommait je vais vous
faire une imitation
oui je sais c'est comme ça et mes yeux
en me de hockey a oui voilà six mois par
ci par là si tout va bien si c'est pas
comme moi juste quoi j'ai parlement
avant deux ans mélissa n'a jamais voté
selon elle les politiques ne parlent pas
à sa génération et il préfère les
plateaux télé aux réseaux sociaux qui
auraient par exemple une pub qui nous
présenterait les candidats à neutre ' à
notre bad niveau bah oui pourquoi pas
j'irai voter ne parle pas à nous
directement fin wayne où ils utiliseront
des mots compliqués entre guillemets
pour qu'on puisse comprendre leur
programme mab là il faut un blocage sur
politiciens annonce et pad entre du tout
ben voila voila je regarde jamais la
télé licence est en phase avec vous deux
vous avez cependant donné moi on se
regarde on ici même là dans le jeu on
reste un peu abasourdi parce que
très peu de gens ne regardent pas la
télé et entonnait mois dans ces parties
où j'appelle mon au real immédiatement
une d'immeubles et voir ce soir comme
d'un des patients désinfecteurs et après
ils me regardent on avait réagi mais une
lime et moi j'ai eu de mon ong hull
hydroxy coquine ya trois mois une forme
très très très grave j'ai failli être
hospitalisé je me suis soigné
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et où je dis ça
moi j'en connais dit sois là
[Applaudissements]
cette nuit d'argent je continue à dire
le jeune âge c'est vrai que c'est un
gros problèmes légués linge en france ce
qu'ils sont beaux sont bons mais ya rien
à faire
la fonderie mbs aluminium et liquides et
des larmes et puis la colère
les 280 salariés viennent d'apprendre
qu'ils vont perdre leur emploi tout en
croit que voilà on arrive dans un club
c'est le club qui ne prend en charge qui
ne trouve tout mais pas du tout pas de
tours est en fait pour l'avoir vécu à
voir bouger pendant quelques années et
ben tu te débrouilles par toi même tu as
les gens ils se rendent pas compte quand
les jeunes voilà deux joueurs c'est
tranquille c'est la life oui aussi
mais c'est à nous de gérer tout ça
l'unique repreneur n'a pas été retenue
par le tribunal
ils se sentent trahis par l'état qui
selon eux ne les a pas été c'est pour ça
qu'ils adaptent de l'abstention on avait
du boulot jusqu'en 2025 et là qu'est ce
qu'on fait on va fermer la boutique
c'est ça la stratégie de l'état des
constructeurs il faut vraiment qu'on
l'aide à reprendre confiance en elle
même est peut-être un petit week-end à
la ville de temps en temps pour faire du
slalom avec sa fille de 13 ans quoi
c'est l'idée frimer dans son village un
coup de voiture et hop direction les
grands magasins moi je veux lui redonner
envie d'aller faire du shopping à
djénine c'est le meilleur antidépresseur
le shopping c'est un morceau d'histoire
qui brille à nouveau après saison de
sommeil 750 millions d'euros
d'investissements et des travaux
colossaux
la samaritaine renaît de ses cendres
faire le grand magasin et 21 cents à la
fonderie à saint-claude les salariés
s'organisent déjà pour résister on est
en train de poser les deux blocs un peu
l'axé les salariés veulent empêcher le
départ des machines et obtenir de
meilleures indemnités de licenciement
mais fini le bazar populaire place à un
écrin dédié aux produits de luxe
peut-être on peut acheter par internet
certainement mais on ne peut pas toucher
les produits on peut pas les voir et on
ne peut pas déjeuné dans un endroit
aussi magnifique par internet
jamais sans mon smartphone mais 83% des
français ne se voit pas passer une
journée entière sans toucher à leur
téléphone selon ce sondage réalisé pour
rico avec une angoisse en particulier la
batterie à plat
38% des français estiment même que la
journée est gâché si leur batterie tombe
à zéro on a tellement pris l'habitude de
rester à la maison maintenant un que le
jour où ils nous laisseront à nouveau
sortir mes enfants pas simplement sortir
et avoir une vie sociale
je crois qu'on va pas tout ça on va
claquer la balle avec tout le monde
mon mari les uniformes il est vraiment
militaire avec le d'uniformes était une
femme avec toi
le fusil
des fantasmes m'a même pu donner la main
on se fait pas la bise directement lac
claqué sur la joue directement shta nous
sommes le 22 jours ils tuent vous savez
que je vous entends très bien mais c'est
pour réveiller la ménagère oui mais sa
voix d' interdire ça ça va interdire des
choses pareilles la ménagère non mais tu
te rends compte
il met des cheveux chez passer ça fait
bizarre
[Musique]
mais c'est mon visage je le reconnais
pas c'est un peu ça l'idée aussi c'est
que tu te reconnais plus est-ce que tu
thème déjà
et ce temps
rien